hey guys and welcome to this X blog this
is the series where I talk about my life
as a PhD student here at the University
of Exeter
now reason I felt like I had to say that
was because apparently since I last
posted a blog I've gained like a
thousand subscribers instantly if you
are one of those subscribers hi hello
I'm saying hello in the comments this
channel just been going really really
fast
recently it's almost like this
community's getting a little bit out of
hand this there's too many of you in
case you're not up-to-date on the videos
which I've been doing most recently I
did a video explaining the physics of
global warming in 146 seconds if you
haven't seen that please do to check it
out I think it's the best scientific
video I've done it's I'd like to do more
like that in the future I also did a
video where I attempt to put makeup on
my girlfriend's face I'd like to think I
did a good job but you can judge for
yourself links on the screen and I'll
put links to all these in the
description I took the millon cancer
support ice bucket challenge and you can
check the video help for that here and
also I did an interesting video which
basically I wanted to see if it was
possible to do a reverse stay in the
life where I asked my subscribers you
know how their day was and I found
reading the comments through that
fascinating if you left the comment on
that video thank you because I got an
insight into I think there's like 200
peoples days you know it was an
incredibly interesting experience to see
just how diverse my subscriber base is
because Google does give you analytics
you know it tells you the age range of
people who watch you it tells you where
they come from but it doesn't give you
individual experiences and I probably
gonna you know put my thoughts on the
subject into a particular video but if
you took part in that thank you so much
and I hope you found it interesting
really through other subscribers days
because no.2 is similar so in the past
these videos have been a little bit
rambling and a bit too long so I'm going
to try and keep this on a little bit
more concise into the point so what have
I been up to so here in Exeter for the
past couple of months it's been quite
quiet because term finished ages and
ages ago and then all the other
graduates left so it's really just been
us researchers and PhD students who've
been around and in a way that was really
nice for a while and it meant you can
get your head down and just get some
work done
although doesn't mean things a little
bit boring but you know that seems to
change what I've been doing on the
research side of things has actually
been really interesting recently so my
research is in climate physics and I'm
looking at this hypothesis but the layer
of atmosphere which were in called the
troposphere
that the pressure and temperature of
that layer of the atmosphere is
controlled by the height of the lid
basically to that p of the atmosphere so
this layer down here is called the
troposphere
and that lid is called the Trop opposed
it's the top of the troposphere and
basically my supervisor has this theory
that if you vary the height of the Trop
opposed then it change induces some
temperature and pressure anomalies in
the rest of the troposphere so this
graph is showing you the temperature
anomalies in the troposphere
so you have height on the vertical axis
and time on the horizontal axis and what
you're looking at is about four years
just under four years of data so what
we've done here is I've taken the annual
cycle out of the temperature so you if I
hadn't done that you'd have seen warmer
temperatures in summer and colder
temperatures in winter you know for the
whole atmosphere and I basically
subtracted an annual cycle from the data
in more technical language I did a
low-pass filter and then we're left with
these anomalies now you'll notice that
there's these quite violent events at
the top of the stratosphere circled them
these are called some stratospheric
warming and you'll notice that you know
they're pretty violent events over the
course of a couple of days the
temperature shoots up so what I did was
I worked with this hypothesis that the
temperature and pressure noise in the
troposphere induced by you know varying
that than the height of the Trop balls
and I took the height of the trauma
pause from some data in the rest of this
dataset and then eliminated the
anomalies from the data so what I did
was I just used the seasonal cycle and
then said well what deviations from that
will this hypothesis caused and I had an
equation which predicted those nominees
and I got a graph which looks like this
now you notice that this is very very
similar to the previous graph if I put
them side-by-side you'll notice that
they're basically identical and I
thought that this graph was going to be
oh wow you know pre hypothesis it's it's
it's very concrete proof it can go in
your thesis bang and I took it to my
supervisor and he was like you know
great work definitely gonna go in your
thesis but we need to ask some more
questions and we need to do this again
and we just do it slightly differently
try a million different iterations and
it's and that's basically the way that
research works is that you know you have
this idea and you say right I want to
test this hypothesis so I'm going to go
away and then you write computer code
for like in this case actually wasn't
that long in some cases it can be very
long time and then you test that
hypothesis and you get a result out and
you go right what does that mean and
then you work with that result and you
say okay well let's try this a little
bit differently and this a little bit
differently and each iteration of that
experiment then tells you something
slightly different and it enables you to
really zero in on a particular aspect so
what I'm now gonna do is basically but
it's difficult to explain but basically
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna consider
the annual cycles slightly differently
and see what kind of anomalies we get by
by treating annual cycle in that
different way this might seem like quite
dry like looking at temperature
anomalies in the atmosphere but to me is
really cool because it's it's physics in
action the atmosphere is the world's
biggest laboratory it's it's it's so
cool however this quiet period over the
summit is seem to end because actually
this weekend when I'm filming this
undergraduate it's gonna be pouring back
into the city and there's gonna be some
student Timothy stuff so I get involved
in loads of singing and I'm so so
looking forward to doing some of that
again this year but I'm also going to
start teaching this year I've been
invited to do various forms of teaching
I don't want to say anything specific
because it might not happen but I'm very
excited that there's some really cool
opportunities to do some stuff the
reason I love being an academia is
because I love doing research and
finding new things out but they all sort
of teaching which is partly why I do
YouTube videos on science because I just
enjoy that sensation of presenting
information in a new way to people and
you don't get it on the internet but in
real life when you see a spark and
someone's eye when they understand
something for the first time that to me
is the best thing in the world lastly I
wanted to talk a little bit about videos
that are coming out soon so I already
said that I'm going to be doing a draw
my life video that is coming probably in
about two weeks I'm probably gonna be
uploading every two weeks in term time
realistically I'd like to upload every
week like I have been recently but I
just have rehearsals pretty much every
night of the week and it's gonna be very
difficult to find time so probably in
two weeks time there's gonna be a draw
my life which hopefully will be
entertaining and then beyond that I'm
also going to be doing a day in the life
video when term is quieten down a bit
and I'm back into a routine
I'm also in the future going to be doing
very excitingly a collaboration with
none other than Jamie miles or Jamie
Mills the original of the Volks blogger
he's coming down to Exeter on a road
trip and we're gonna do some videos
together but more on that close to the
time but I would like to get your input
I would like you to tell me what kind of
videos you'd like me to make but I'd
like you to tell me what kind of science
videos you'd like me to make because I
really enjoyed doing the global-warming
video and before that the relativity
video about the world's simplest clock
you haven't seen that there'll be a
blink on the screen in the description
now I want this channel to kind of
develop along two prongs really because
I want this channel to be sort of vlog
II type stuff like I've been doing and
between the tea my girlfriend's makeup
and doing day in the life video it's
that kind of thing almost like a vlogger
personality thing but I also want to do
some more science videos and be more
like like in the comments people have
been saying about minutephysics and
visa-versa and scishow and doing more
educational kind of videos so my
specialty is physics and climate but
what kind of things would you like me to
do what particular aspects do you think
would make good videos because you guys
are a phenomenal audience you some of
you have way more accomplished than I am
way more motivated oh I feel like I
should be watching your videos not the
other way around so what would you like
to see what videos would you like me to
make because fundamentally I think you
know better than I do
that is more than enough nonsense for
this video I'm going to leave it there
I'll report back in another vlog in a
couple of weeks letting you know how
term is going and if anything exciting
is happening more likely than not with
more information about this Jamie
collaboration and thank you very very
much for watching and leave your
thoughts in the description in the
description I've been doing this for
years I still get it wrong leave your
thoughts in the comments about what
videos I should be doing thanks very
much guys